welcome to this video we I got requests
for playing a vols own tournament again
on chest cube and I just locked on then
check to what what's going on this one
tournament running here we see town left
24 minutes so it's um I'm here yes I'm
sorry I'm six minutes late to the
tournament so basically three games
behind the leaders I'm not too and not
easy to to catch but let's see what what
I can do this is two minute chests I
should double here no it's not moving
great if I get non worse it will be very
tricky I haven't played a tournament
here for our ok resins in response ok so
i'm not sure if they have implemented
some some rule that that let-let's oops
let's win quicker oh this is really not
a very fast animation I actually have
never played the chest cube tournament
on this computer and with this
particular browser setup maybe there is
some way to make it welcome at the
moment this is a bit problematic very
slow animation ok I've sacrificed a pcl
to to get his son can't get his King out
in the yoga and let's see what happens
maybe 95 coming I could also i should
also play a 3 before if possible let's
do this first that I don't give up
big material here all right this is
saying no better check the Queen you
first i want to take on e6 would be nice
if he takes this rook c7 wow we look at
this not good and he's 6 coming yeah
this is taking too long really I cannot
take because of the the rook here
hanging oops yeah I was hoping that this
this is strong now if I think I can take
him OOP g8 is quite quite dangerous to
put it mildly
I don't see made I mean this is this is
winning but it's not the direct
checkmate we just haven't made but he
can take only one and continue I can
still enter this as a pre move and
lonely yeah Vicky takes would take the
rook African I g5 check again this will
will be a maid at the end why can take
d5 and al it's maybe maybe even easier
just taking too long if you want to
catch up being a some time down you need
to to really win it very quickly and
this is really too long page three mate
cool 23 points down yeah I need to need
very quick wins oh wow okay actually I
only reckoned with efore and I was too
late and taking it back so let's make em
crazy gambit out of it at least I've got
good development going Bishop f2s a
threat or 94
okay yeah it's not great here but at
least them I have pieces out 95mm sir is
a problem maybe not much I can do about
it I want to get in 95 guess you use
this pin on the on the night mm-hm is
playing this quite well
yeah the gphone is the only only real
hope him but he can always play Bishop
g3 and block it completely I can take on
e5 and on f6 g7x these have the same
okay didn't do that maybe I can get an
f5 oh this is this ass is hanging ya can
still take them need to use the g file
here
maybe look h5 something like that using
this route g3 threat now I came back to
to g6 also okay 37 seconds yeah it will
be very tricky if I'm if I'm getting a
very low on time because of this very
slow animation I mean moose are really
really slow I'm not very slowly with the
mouse but it's the technical side of
things it is tricky these playing this
really are quite good young for this for
this rating 1500 okay there is some
blunder here and there but in general
he's fighting this very nicely okay
still far too slow 21 points behind I
need one hour to a real quick wins then
I can can get back into him into things
but it's really necessary to win to win
quickly so i probably should play some
and very done c5 grade hey the only move
that makes f4 really bad Oh
he five was of course been quite helpful
12 Bishop badly one Bishop c4 in Bishop
c4 yeah now we cannot really cancel oh
this is I don't do how do you actually
meet him me like this here Bishop g5 at
least win7 to the house and this is
almost the maid is this a maid and a
couple of moves over okay but this was
good quick win Wow someone is fit eight
games this is quite nice better not yeah
that's not very suitable to win quickly
yeah hey 95 wow that's an ambitious move
yeah I'll get counter play here Queen a5
threatening to take on g4
yeah that's very nice good like actually
queen d 5 is just a pretty meaningless
check ya got all pieces into the game
that's nice um yes back row rank is also
a bit weak as long as the bishop is here
and i can i can switch it over to the
Kings side we should be four is a big
threat now he should play a three I
guess nope didn't do that but this also
means that G to mate which to mate and
the Queen you're saying so um yeah okay
come on one or two quick wins I really
want to want to get in down you signed I
don't know why but I like it come on one
or two quickens should be possible this
is crazy I know but it it tends to
irritate white players immensely
and we can take only five that was
stupid I mean okay it's it's still still
probably in some way playable wow this
is not great need to gather f7 year ah
this was a weird we had moved that I
played uno he can take d 5 I didn't do
that okay well this is he can take this
but I have some some sort of
compensation on be to me a very weird
maybe maybe you can take d phi of here
that's that's may be possible yeah I
should play Bishop me sick since on
stage but first take the rook and I know
he's attacking listen need to retreat so
what what is going on here three I'm not
materially Donald I material up that's a
quite amazing how did that happen it
looked like I should be should be done
stuff I guess he didn't didn't take what
what I offered him Queen here I can play
g6 okay let's get let's get out of this
no okay yeah that's a really wacky stuff
let's let's move the upon go for direct
player the rookie only one rookie to
Queenie ones check made the tools or
three moves something like that and now
I can take that was the idea one idea
gettin 2d to check here I can retreat
this should be okay Oh is easy to
overlook stuff with this this time
control of course ya to pieces up and he
will lose on time if that wasn't quick
enough probably but at least then two
games behind come on that's one of the
higher rated guys I'll go back to an
open Cecily
you trying to open up the position
quickly fighting 45 that's that's the
key once you get get to the night 35
it's very nice if possible like this
Queen takes rook takes Bishop g5 for
something to to take note off I must
take with the King unfortunately that's
not ideal but not not not a terrible
problem if you would take the night I
would still have a very dominant bishop
I'm looking for an opening after the
files here I can still get some Beck
taking clay going I can take this why
couldn't I take this I played look see
one I didn't put it back properly this
is this is nonsense of course and I
wanted he just blundered blunted
material there and I wanted to take up a
song but I put it back wrongly mmm
that's bad also was very simply winning
of course now i'm still better but it's
not so clear if i can win objectively
speaking I probably shouldn't but okay i
still have weaknesses that i can attack
like those pawns here and look a six is
also source of how a play for me
yeah let's let's go to g6 here okay I
must must make sure that the g porn is
doing no harm okay how to do that um the
exchange sac is probably a possibility
maybe I can operate with this idea yeah
okay this is winning with the pawn the
bishop is just keeping everything
together and the form promotes that
would be nice if they would resign
assume as I need to win really quickly
okay four minutes left yeah that's
probably not going to work out unless
this is a very quick win five pre moving
and that's totally wacky but okay normal
means i won't win so quickly yes already
is quite nice I guess Queenie chewy
probably should do oops yeah that's not
a problem I win a big temple here on
mine f6 and ice taking its time no
that's not good
oops come on thanks still a slight
chance if I win if I wouldn't really
quickly Oliver take the number one guy
but you probably will get a game in soon
yeah I don't want to just give me a game
give me a game come on yes Fanny Fanny
decent layer with 2,000 rating yeah
that's a nice position but not one you
have you win particularly quickly 95 or
so quite nice no
yeah that's it's also very nice but tune
it's not a quick win I really need to
play instantly all the time other than
otherwise I I don't them I simply I'm
not quick enough
trading rooks would be nice or I get to
be formed you try to get get the edge
porn rolling I think I'm promoting this
and it's it's it's in there is no of
course is not going yeah you need some
some help with those kind of kind of
chases people resigning a cooling down
as such help or two queens down for that
matter and bought it so fourth place
fourth place let me check it at the end
how did he get three games in this guy
he was oh wow sometimes how quickly I
can finish their games yeah I started
six minutes late and okay I didn't get
the last point because the tournament
ended and okay well 33 games is so it's
also what I'm behind at the end i won
all 9 games without any big trouble but
I didn't do it quick enough really this
is sometimes sometimes really the issue
yeah okay I hope you enjoyed it I'll try
to play those kind of tournaments once
in a while and it's simply better to
start right when the tournament is
beginning but when i was logging in it
had just started this five minutes late
and the next one was only a far later in
the day when I wasn't sure
that it can make it so it's a bit
incomplete this thing but hope you still
enjoyed it thanks for watching